in today's modern era everything around
us is digital and away from one single
click or tap where necessary services
and fantastic adventures are at your
fingertips
so right from online shopping to
explorations anything can be done at
ease with your daily driver i.e the
smartphones
to enhance user experience to the next
level advanced technology like app
development reality technologies and
simulations come into picture
and ar
is one among them
so with a warm welcome let's get started
in this new video of simply learn where
we will be discussing the top five er
applications in current trend with the
features and applications
in our daily lives everything is quite
easy to access and all you need is a
smartphone
right from daily needs like groceries
fantastic adventures or games or even
for studies via online learning or
classes which is easy convenient and
also free to use over the internet to
provide a better user experience app
developing companies feature their
products by refining them by adding an
additional feature or including other
technologies like ai optimized search
engines
ar etc and many more to act as a part of
the app itself
now let's focus on what ar technology is
but before that
let's cover the agenda of this video
so without any further delay let's get
on to the objective of this video
as a part of our video first we will
discuss what is ar technology
and what is the need for ar technology
moving on to the best top 5 ar
applications
and a quick comparison on common key
factors at the end
and after that we will have a quick
conclusion
[Music]
but before moving any further let's
understand what is ar
ar or augmented reality is one among
reality technology but the primary goal
is to embed digital information by using
sensors and simulations on a real one
in other words er is an interactive
method of presenting relevant digital
information on the physical environment
for example apps have occupied most
aspects of needs irrespective of their
need category and usage
apps like google lens simplify the
search
by capturing images
instagram and snapchat to share photos
and enhance photos by applying filters
google maps for navigation
and ar core
to power graphics for gaming and other
ar applications
so now what is the need for ar
the invention of new technology takes
place to overcome the difficulties in
current or existing technology
so let's now understand the need or the
emergence of ar technology
in the early 90s ar was first introduced
and implemented in the u.s air force for
navigation post-which ar technology set
its footprint not only in the field of
aviation but also towards other sectors
like entertainment gaming and many more
to enhance user experience
the sole need for ar is ar combines
digital information on the physical
on
wire sensors and graphics
it helps produce remote operations
eliminating hindrance like need for an
actual workspace it enhances better
decision making and it's quite easy to
access right from a smartphone
so coming on to the best ar applications
in 2022
every year almost 2.4 million apps are
being developed and published per year
with unlimited downloads by our users
not only apps even adventurous games
like a battleground arcade games
brainstorming etc
now let's move to
the top
best ar apps in 2022. first we have a
wikitude one of the popular and mostly
used ar platforms to develop ar
mobile apps and prototypes allowing
developers to implement
geolocation features image tracking and
object recognition
next we have apple air kit
which lets developers easily design and
develop applications by using facial
tracking
stable and fast motion tracking etc
moving towards augmented it is the
world's only ai powered connecting
worker platform aim to improve the
safety quality and productivity
standards
in the manufacturing and service sector
then we have
ar core
ar core is one among other ar platforms
that follows three key technologies for
embedding virtual content individual
environments namely motion tracking
environmental recognition and lighting
recognition
next we have
euphoria
it is a powerful ar platform to develop
ar applications to enable business to
provide an immersive ar experience to
their customers
now on to the comparison
the key factors
that we are going to discuss for the top
five of best ar apps
are
cost effective
nowadays most of the apps are free but
to enjoy our access premium content
these contents are chargeable in terms
of membership fees available in both
short-term and long-term access
security
cyber attacks are quite common and very
often nowadays for no reason despite
whether it's an mnc i.t or a working
professional to avoid unauthorized
access to data security and privacy
plays a major role in safeguarding your
professional information
ai
due to technology and advancement we
make machines think and provide
suggestions and recommendations via the
use of algorithms and analysis
which helps better decision making
ai is easily accessible and a built-in
feature of most applications
next is
multi-platform
most of the apps we use in our
day-to-day lives in platform dependent
as these apps can be used in multiple
platforms multiple devices
irrespective of operating system like
windows mac os android and many more for
example apps like whatsapp microsoft
teams and etc
and next we have storage not only
safeguarding data but also storing data
plays a major role
cloud storage is quite common and a fast
safe and secure storage system that is
easy to access
its advanced security system includes
encryption standards to protect users
data and privacy
now let's move on to towards comparison
on the above mentioned key factors
at first we have wikitube
wikitude doesn't meet
the criteria of cost effectiveness as
wikitoo needs membership access to
access premium
features as the membership we start at
2490 euro
to talk about security features there is
no info
moving towards ai wikitude doesn't use
the feature of ai as we use slam
instant tracking object and scene
recognition
followed by geolocation based ar and
image recognition
to talk about multi-platform support
apps develop with the use of wikitude
supports multi-platform access
and towards storage wikitude supports
cloud storage
now to talk about the apple ar kit
apple air kit is free towards beta
version for its developers whereas the
stable release is chargeable thus
eliminating cost-effectiveness
towards security it is provided with
in-app security features to disable
sensitive information for sharing
towards ai there is no information on it
this platform doesn't need the
requirements of multi-platform and
storage as apps
and for storage also it doesn't have any
feature
towards augmented at first there is no
information about the cost effectiveness
or pricing for using this software
augmented support security features
using data hosting servers
providers to secure data
it also supports ai and multi-platform
support and towards too rich augmented
does not support cloud storage
moving towards ar core ar core by google
llc supports all the key features
as it's free to access as most of us use
android os and ar core is embedded as a
part of android to provide air services
both in gaming and productivity
it supports security features with the
help of encryption to keep data private
and offer security features like safe
browsing security checkup
and step verification etc
ar core uses ai to suggest products and
services and supports multi-platform as
app build for android can be accessed in
other platforms too and it supports
cloud storage facility as well
and at the end we have bufforia
buforia does not support cost
effectiveness as add-ons or premium
facilities are chargeable
towards security it has built-in
security features along with content
encryption secure authentication and
multi-layered application security
management
and also this platform supports other
features like ai multi-platform access
and storage facilities
so now we have reached to the end of
this module
in today's video we have discussed what
air technology is the need for ar
with the best or top ar apps used in
current trend followed by comparison of
top application based on key factors the
field of app development is wide open
recently app development have been quite
easy as kids at the age of 9 and 10 are
establishing their empire by developing
apps
but we should choose the best one that
suits our needs provides data protection
and maintains users privacy
i hope you have enjoyed this video post
your questions and feedbacks are welcome
in the comment section below
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel simply
learn and do hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply here
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here